auf und bediene präsentiert von der
leyen für alle wohl engert oder weniger
lang weg sind kult gerstner und mike
wittner aus ton suchen das einfache
leben mit ihren kindern wandern sie aus
nach costa rica beatrice und marcelo
holzer aus dem kanton solothurn wurden
noch einmal durchstarten
auf kreta eröffnen sie eine bar von
clarus nach australien familie landolt
möchte mit den ureinwohnern
zusammenarbeiten und betreibt ein ferien
resort in down under
[Musik]
es ist eine fantastische aussicht die
sich den auswanderern in costa rica
bietet doch mike wittner und seine
familie haben keine augen für die
schönheit ihrer neuen heimat sie packen
schon wieder
erst vor fünf wochen ist die familie in
zwei vielen häuser gezogen heimisch hat
sie sich hier nieder runde gut und den
usa
das ist die schlachtordnung ist ab heute
abend schlafen sie in ihrem neuen haus
es steht nur ein paar kilometer weiter
in der letzten folge war der schock bei
mutter nicole groß als sie in den ferien
bungalows andrang gibt es hier nicht
nein das ist nicht angeschlossen
marcel und tricks buchholzer kamen auf
kreta an ihre alltäglichen sticheleien
haben sie mitgenommen kam eingerichtet
suchten sie eine bar die sie übernehmen
könnten
miriam landolt absolvierte ihre letzten
wochen als schulleiterin in class
ehemann übernahm währenddessen in
australien das ferienressort und kämpfte
mit der finanzierung der liegenschaft
wir tun unser bestes um den termin zu
halten
[Musik]
es ist ein paradiesisches fleckchen erde
der ort santa teresa an der westküste
costa ricas während der hochsaison von
dezember bis april wird das dorf von
wellenreitern überschwemmt
mike und nicole sind das erste mal vor
13 jahren nach costa rica gekommen und
haben sich in das besondere lebensgefühl
verliebt jetzt wollen sie hier wurzeln
schlagen im neuen haus mit pool
sie haben es vor wenigen tagen gekauft
[Musik]
match dieses probleme mit costa rica für
grunder hat die natur und musik
das passiert auch strom abnehmen mit
einem wermutstropfen orchester haben sie
zwar nichts 40
die ränder gerätes ist ich glaube es ist
gut sehr gut
[Musik]
sieht so das einfache leben aus
down under sind mirja julian und jannis
voll in ihrem element
[Musik]
die kinder der familien an bord haben
das gelände des ferienresorts friday
creed für sich erobert es ist ein
riesiger abenteuerspielplatz 40 hektar
kurs hast du reinigungsmittel für die
fenster ja ich nehme diesen lappen zum
putzen und den zum trocknen vaterspiel
hilft putzen
seit drei wochen ist der familienvater
mit seinen kindern in australien ohne
mutter miriam schön wartet darauf dass
seine frau die betreuung der häuser und
gäste übernimmt er kümmert sich um die
finanzen und springt ein wo es nötig ist
nicht profi bis zum spiel bis zum das
machen wir jetzt vielleicht auch mal
länger als andere aber so sachen die
sich selber macht kontrollieren
[Musik]
in der schweiz sind die letzten tage vor
miriams abreise angebrochen
[Musik]
miriam will abschied nehmen
ein letztes mal geht sie auf den
friedhof von wangs im st galler oberland
juroren ihre großeltern und weitere
vorfahren die ihr sehr viel bedeutet
haben das im griff sie mit den award
abstauben dauer marc rindert händler
miriam hat früher regelmäßig zwiesprache
gehalten mit ihren ahnen vor allem in
schwierigen lebenssituationen noch so
viele sms kraft nicht genannt und dann
noch nicht so richtig die krise geraten
[Musik]
auch in australien steht ein abschied
bevor war das schön muss seine kinder
verlassen und zurück in die schweiz
noch bevor mutter miriam hier eintrifft
seinen job als finanzchef eines
international tätigen unternehmens hat
schön behalten
der traum vom auswandern bedeutet für
ihn über 10.000 kilometer pendeln wird
das hat finanzielle sieg beliebte
pflichten moment weniger stress für mich
raus haben wir jetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
geworden und der untröstliche bergsport
[Musik]
bis mutter miriam endlich kommt schaut
janet eine freundin der familie nach den
kindern
[Musik]
die cafés am hafen von nicola sind
menschenleer
es ist vor saison seit sechs wochen
wohnt marcel buchholz mit seiner frau
auf kreta freunde haben die solo tour
noch keine gefunden dafür aber ein lokal
seit eineinhalb jahren ist es
geschlossen und dabei muss man eine neue
karriere
thomas neubert ruf und zusätzlich
natürlich schon morgen gesunden
[Applaus]
das ist zweifach sie will ja auch wo
sind denn wir das eigentlich kaputt
machen aber da sie nicht mit den und sie
werden musste
roßhaupten mich nicht aus der krise
als nächstes muss war soll beim anwalt
den vertrag für die bar unterzeichnet
und die ablöse für das inventar bezahlen
[Musik]
mike nicole und die kinder tragen die
letzten sachen ins neue zuhause
die kinder haben die zimmer schon
verteilt einziges thema braucht das haus
mussten sie vor ort nicht lange suchen
sie haben es bereits in thun im internet
entdeckt die villa hat nur vier zimmer
aber dafür drei bäder
es hat etliche umwege gebraucht bis ich
nicole und mike auf dieses haus einigen
konnten
sarkozy und klimaanlage arbeit und das
leben also gemacht darum kaufen
die präsidentin der komiker noch immer
nicht nur mit ring und und hung und
glückliche frau zufriedenes leben schön
wenn die welt so einfach sein kann
[Musik]
um direkt auf kreta ist die wohnung
eingerichtet aber katze kaschel hat sich
was eingefangen wochen zu erwarten
seit zehn tagen engagement per kopf 7
kahle stellen wir sind wir uns sorgen
machen ganz große ausnahme aus dem
schönen kreta dankbar für ein kurzes
lied bekannt zu machen
[Musik]
welche schon noch was ist so groß dass
man im stau
juli fällt natürlich noch mit
[Musik]
bis vor zwei monaten war marcel noch als
vertreter für filtertechnik in der
schweiz unterwegs tricks arbeitete in
einem schuljahr
während marcel darauf brennt mit der
bahre loszulegen betriebs das projekt
entspannt angehen
[Musik]
das geld ist nach dem anderen
vergewaltigen und morden mit richtig cm
gross aber für de stimmt für mich dem
tweet erwünscht mädchen vorgenommen und
das war dem rezept und jetzt geht auch
ums geld doch ums finanzielle
jetzt dort so ein großer betrag kaufen
ich die chance dass ich hier meinen
rhetorik
aber nichts da mit dem man auf die fahne
[Musik]
am flughafen in zürich sucht miriam
ihren mann will kommt alleine ohne
kinder ein seltsames gefühl für das
ehepaar die kinder so weit entfernt zu
wissen ihre kinder sind in australien
angekommen
aber ob sich miriams traum vom ferien
resort überhaupt finanzieren lässt ist
weiterhin unklar
ihre idee sie suchen in der schweiz
investoren die so schnell wie möglich in
das geschäft mit einsteigen
gleich nach ankunft haben sie eine
verabredung die landolt treffen den
gastro unternehmer michelle p klar mit
dem sie bekannt sind
was aber zu fairen konditionen ausfielen
die finanzierung bleibt ein ungelöstes
problem um das sich die beiden dringend
kümmern müssen
[Musik]
morgen an der pazifikküste
der tag beginnt für mike und seine
familie mit einem ausflug zum strand
diese liegt keine fünf minuten von ihrem
haus entfernt
das ist großer sport
ich war auch am strand sitzen und den
wellenreitern zu sehen nicole scheint
zufrieden mit sich und der welt
[Musik]
aber auch im paradies beginnt irgendwann
einmal der alltag
bald müssen die kinder in die schule und
maike und nicole beginnen mit der
planung der bungalows auf ihrem
grundstück die sie vermieten möchten
[Musik]
wiedersehensfreude in australien mutter
miriam ist in coffs harbour angekommen
sechs wochen lang war sie von ihren
kindern getrennt
[Musik]
merian kann nun endlich wieder für ihre
kinder da sein doch es wartet viel
arbeit auf sie in ferien resort
am anderen ende der welt stürzt sich in
die arbeit
er ist finanzchef eines
technologiekonzerns der welt weit über
4.000 mitarbeiter beschäftigt wie sony
oder und mit der familie und will auch
für die flamme für das projekt sind
finden die wenn es traurig dann
irgendwie doch nicht einen schritt
zurücktreten und somit auch einen dienst
für familien stellen
den job zu behalten weiß idee wäre es
nach seiner frau miriam gegangen wäre er
nicht hier und dann bei der familie in
australien doch schön möchte nicht alles
auf eine karte setzen auf seinen
sicheren lohn will er momentan nicht
verzichten
das wären resort im land der aborigines
hat noch zu wenige gäste funktion
operative betrieb sie wenn man das löste
spirituell ein beispiel für den
bassisten ständig das ist okay für mich
und dass das spirituelle danke das ist
muss ich sage du bist das verstehen dass
ich sagen
[Musik]
zurück auf beide krieg die
stammesältesten walker ist mit ihrer
tochter gekommen
merian kennt die frauen schon seit
vielen jahren als junge erwachsene hat
sie ein jahr in australien gelebt
seitdem ist miriam von den aborigines
und ihrer kultur fasziniert ich möchte
mich bei denen bedanken dass sie miriam
zu uns ins land der grünberger gebracht
haben
willkommen zu hause gut dass du da bist
danke dass hier die stellung gehalten
habt im kreis der australischen freunde
fühlt sich miriam zu hause
[Musik]
immer wieder weg
miriam ist an den ort ihrer träume
zurückgekehrt
auf kreta ist der große tag da heute
wollen marcel und tricks die weichen für
ihr neues leben stellen in ihrer tasche
verwahrt tricks dafür ein dickes bündel
scheine
so ist es bei hofe begann sofort mit dem
geld geht's zum anwalt dort
unterzeichnen marcel und tricks den
pachtvertrag der anwalt erwartet das
ehepaar bereits im büro in seinem
wohnhaus tricks wird herzlich von ella
der maklerin begrüßt sie hat die bar
vermittelt
holzers sind pünktlich wer fehlt ist die
hausbesitzerin pop ohne das okay der
hausbesitzerin gibt es keine
vertragsunterzeichnung für die bahn
der termin wird verschoben
[Musik]
ich bin die beste bank
das geld bekommt der vorbesitzer der bar
als ablöse für das inventar müssen sie
40.000 euro bezahlen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für die baby affen hat mutter nicole
keine zeit sie bereitet schulsachen vor
demnächst müssen die kinder raus aus der
vertrauten umgebung mike müht sich
derweil draußen mit dem internet
anschluss ab
[Musik]
aus der schweiz meldet sich unvermittelt
nicoles beste freundin
[Musik]
ja ja ich glaube schon nach kurzer zeit
reicht die verbindung ab nicole hätte
ihrer freundin noch so viel zu erzählen
aber das geht nicht mehr so einfach
es wird funktionieren
so stieg auf
[Musik]
die stille trügt im ferien resort der
familie randolph hat sich eine
hochzeitsgesellschaft mit 80 gästen
eingemietet wir dekorieren noch fertig
und dann brechen wir wahrscheinlich auf
um vier kommen wir wieder
bis dahin bin ich zurück dann machen wir
eine probe melde dich wenn du etwas
brauchst das resort ist ausgebucht
miriam ist für 9 ferienhäuser zuständig
keine zeit sich auszuruhen
trotz kette vor kurzem hatte miriam in
der schweiz noch eine schule geleitet
in australien ist sie nun hotel
managerin zimmermädchen und
hausmeisterin in einer nur eine putzfrau
und ein gärtner helfen ihr miriam und
ihre familie sind dringend auf einnahmen
angewiesen
solange das ressort nicht vollständig
bezahlt ist haben sie es nur gepachtet
monat für monat müssen sie rund 12000
franken aufbringen für bis zu 280
franken welche gäste pro nacht bezahlen
wollen sie ein zimmer ohne ungeziefer
und tatsächlich miriam hat eine spinne
entdeckt
ich sag ja groß genug also gott seine
technik kann
[Musik]
auf kreta herrscht ratlosigkeit warum
hat die hausbesitzerin den termin
platzen lassen
[Musik]
nach der enttäuschung mit dem vertrag
versuchen sich die buchholzer abzulenken
und die schönen zeiten kretas zu
genießen
das glück könnte perfekt werden wenn sie
sich nicht mit aabar kalkulieren
[Musik]
frühmorgens in mittelamerika nikola hat
nicht besonders gut geschlafen
heute ist schulbeginn
doch wie läuft es an der internationalen
schule alle sind verunsichert
sportlich haben und dann ging es
irgendwie hab ich ja ja ich verspreche
dass ich jetzt so richtig gedacht das
ist jetzt für sein soll jetzt für das
ist schon sehr sehr leid so lukits uns
eine neue großanlage richtigen spanisch
und nachmittag in der pause wohl dass
die selbstliebe der bloomberg
aber dies konnte frühesten was den
kindern den einstieg in die schule ein
wenig erleichtert ist dass sie zu dritt
sind und sich gegenseitig unterstützen
können
[Musik]
festliche stimmung auf weide krieg
das ja wort unter freiem himmel vor
freude bei der braut und bei miriam
kommen erinnerungen hoch
[Musik]
hier ist dabei viel haben und sich auf
sehr spezielle sinne transparenz
ich bin überzeugt dass es schon rolle
spielte schon mit bezüglich dafür gratis
und ich glaube oder ein spezieller oder
italien spielt karoline aber ich glaube
dass es wichtig ist
das ist eine größe von verspielt
qualitäten ich glaube die entwicklung
oder irgendwelchen sie dann immer
glücklich genommen weil wir gratulieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in glarus schleppt ehemann schon die
letzten persönlichen gegenstände aus dem
haus der familie um geld zu sparen
wollen landes das ehemalige
herrschaftshaus vermieten will kommt bis
auf weiteres bei freunden unter
[Musik]
die situation zurzeit dass sie da die
unterstützung leichter wo man eine
braucht sich auch nicht 30.000 schweizer
bertrand von der familie
das macht einen natürlich schon wieder
dann machen wir das nicht sagen aber in
der frage ist das ganze modell einfach
zuwider
nächste woche bei auf und davon
schüler reist wieder zu seiner familie
nach australien
dort muss er mit dem verkäufer des
ferienresorts verhandeln
[Musik]
schulbeginn in costa rica mike und
nicole müssen eine familie vor die tür
setzen ihre bleibe ist teil von mikes
bungalow projekt auf kreta bekommt
marcel endlich den schlüssel für die bar
ehefrau tricks misstraut dem die nach
wie vor und auch zu hause herrscht dicke
luft
muss ich die gar nicht mehr so weit
kommen
si
rufst du
prof
sie bleiben
[Musik]
sie waren das abenteuer
sie wandern aus schweizer radio und
fernsehen möchte sie bei ihrem neuanfang
bereiten
die kameras sind mit dabei wenn sie ihr
altes leben gegen ein neues eintauschen
melden sie an oder schreiben sie an
schweizer radio und fernsehen stichwort
auswandern 80 52 zügig auf und tina voß
präsentiert wurde der leyen für alle
wohl engert oder weniger lang weg sind